pas joué ensemble à the voice presque
keats d'accord alors je vais choisir
certains d'entre vous ils vont chanter
sauf que grâce à un filtre qui a ici on
va vous mettre une tête d'enfant
je voulais voir matheux t as well as et
là on a déjà fait une fois ces boulets
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est génial il est dégueulasse je suis
le meilleur sur sa table vous trouverez
pas bien alors qu'il me sentais tient
attributions t.ac.a fabien lecoeuvre
descente et on va en faire rien que là
juste pour voir la tête et voir fabien
lecoeuvre là tu te tais s'atténue marcel
amont je pense frère mais bien un
tabouret pour qu'il monte sur wii et
walla walla faire quoi
cet anniversaire est un verbe la berd
bien venir vas-y limites argué
[Applaudissements]
le revendeur
anne-isabelle va digérer
m
[Musique]
sa marque pour ce siècle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
l'agent menor ne pas dire voilà là c'est
qu'à mon sérieux on se rend compte et me
antoinette et si ça marche au lasso min
toi tu vas voir mais oh ça va
hi media
mais moi c'est le pire fois c'est
heureusement jean michel maire n'est pas
producteur d'émissions simon l'a
rajeunie savez quoi
la marche aura pas de frais et charges
j'avais fini c'est pas la peine c'est
qu'il est mort et les vases et kelly et
[ __ ] il venait kelly b n'est jamais
mieux ni abidal non non non valérie
valérie à l'isi
je vous parle je voulais que ça passe
bien s'y met mais le devant pour toutes
les missions
c'est bien quand je me déguise en tout
cas on voudra motards bien mal à
l'histoire et à mon approche toi ça fait
pas de moi très faible on a la même de
tes frères oui ah ouais c'est la même
même faisait peur lui